PALAK DALAL BHATIA:
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for being here.
I'm Palak.
I'm a product manager on
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and I have with me Ken.
KEN OWENS: Hi, I'm Ken Owens.
I'm a software engineer on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
I work on the Workloads Team.
And in open-source, I contribute
primarily to the workloads API.
That's in the special
interest group applications,
and I'm a co-chair
of that group.
PALAK DALAL BHATIA:
So today we'll
talk about how to build portable
data processing workloads
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
The amount of data that
companies are dealing with
is exploding.
Information is a
valuable commodity.
There's an increasing
need to generate
relevant and intelligent
insights from that data
to make business
critical decisions.
But doing so is not
easy, especially when
you're dealing with a humongous
amount of data and tools
and technologies that are
changing at a rapid pace.
Users need a way to incorporate
intelligent decision-making
in their applications,
while iterating quickly
on their applications.
They also want to use the
latest machine learning and data
processing technologies in a
way which is easy to understand,
and doesn't have a very
steep learning curve.
Developers need to offload the
operational burden of actually
deploying and managing an
application in production
clusters, while at
the same time they
are asking for high
performance and acceleration
to get intelligent insights
at a lightning pace.
Enter containers and Kubernetes.
Containers are sealed
deployment units
that provide efficient
isolation, reusability,
and portability.
Through containers you can
modernize your infrastructure,
and launch and iterate
on features much faster.
Kubernetes has emerged as the
leading container orchestration
platform.
It does all the
heavy lifting for you
for managing, operating,
upgrading, and scaling
your production clusters.
Moreover, it is
open-source, so you
can move your applications
and workloads to any cloud
without any vendor login.
Today, we will talk about
how Kubernetes provides
the best platform for
running those data processing
applications.
We will show you a demo,
and a technical deep dive
on both Spark and Airflow
applications on Kubernetes.
Over to you, Ken.
KEN OWENS: So today I
want to talk a little bit
about the pieces that you use
to build a data processing
application on
top of Kubernetes.
How many of you guys
are familiar with pods?
Most of you.
So, most of you have
used Kubernetes,
or have some experience with it.
So, this might be a bit
of an overview for you.
So Kubernetes is
all about resources.
When you create a pod,
a volume, whatever,
it's mirrored by
some real object,
or some object in storage
inside of the system.
At the base you've got a pod.
This is your atom of
scheduling, resource allocation.
It's basically a loosely,
or tightly coupled set
of containers, with a shared
name space, shared networking,
and volumes.
And they have a
shared lifecycle.
They live together,
they die together.
Usually you only run
one container per pod,
unless you've got side
cars, but sometimes you
run more than one.
So volumes, PVs, and PVCs.
These are the atoms
of durable storage.
So a volume is basically
something that appears inside
of your pod on the file system.
You can use it to
access your data.
If it's not backed by a
PV, then it's ephemeral.
It disappears and the pod dies.
If it is backed by a
PV, on Google Cloud
it's backed by a
persistent disk.
When the pod dies, your
data's still in the disk.
PVCs are the way you
associate those PVs.
It's the way you
provision those PVs.
It's the way you get your
volumes into your pod,
and get your data off.
That's interesting,
but you also need
to get data across the
network into a pod.
To do that, you use services.
And this is basically
the atom of networking.
It programs network to
route traffic to pods.
And it may provision
load balancers
if you expose it externally.
So pods, it's the basic
workload you can run.
Just one single pod, right?
But it's not very interesting.
In comes the workloads API.
So deployments
and replica sets--
these are for your
12 factor apps.
It might not be
interesting for data
processing in specific, like
your core data processing
workloads.
But you still need
to 12 factor apps
in order to access those
workloads, in order
to have administrative consoles.
And all a deployment
is, is basically,
I'm going to replicate this pod,
in an identical way n times.
And when I update it, I update
it in a consistent manner,
but I can do it concurrently.
So if I have three pods, I
can update two at a time.
Not particularly
good for databases.
Not particularly good
for stateful applications
in general.
That is why we
created StatefulSets.
So StatefulSet creates n pods in
the same way a deployment does.
But these pods are
different in that they
have durable provision
storage, and they also
have a durable network identity.
And what that means
is if you kill the pod
and you bring it back,
it gets the same storage.
It gets the same C name, it
gets the same SRV records.
The rollouts are
slightly different, too.
They're not concurrent.
They're ordered, and sequential.
Meaning that if I
have three pods,
I wait till pod one
is running and ready
before I launch pod two.
If pod two dies, I
don't kill pod one
until pod two is
completely terminated.
And then DaemonSets
create one pod
for every node in the cluster.
From a perspective
of data processing,
if you're running something like
HDFS, or any other distributed
file system, your
data nodes, you
want to put them on a particular
set of nodes in the cluster.
You don't want n of them
when a new node comes up.
You want a new data node.
DaemonSets allow you to do that.
So those are all interesting
from the perspective
of workloads that
run continuously.
The pods of a StatefulSet,
if they do terminate they get
restarted.
Same for deployment,
same for a DaemonSet.
But with Batch Workloads,
you have a difference, right?
They run to completion.
If I start a Spark job, I want
the job to eventually stop
running when it's completed.
Maybe I want it to
restart if it failed.
That's where job comes in.
Creates pods that
run to completion,
counts numbers of successes.
And once a specified number
of successes have occurred,
the job terminates, and it says
it's completed successfully.
And CronJobs are just a way
to manage time-based jobs.
You can do one offs, you
can do repeating ones that
run at a specific interval.
So, the one thing
we realized when
we were building
the Kubernetes API,
is that we can build
you primitives,
but we can't build
every primitive
you're ever going to need.
So none of the resources
are actually special.
You can bring your
own resources.
These are custom
resource definitions.
And it basically allows you just
to define your own resource.
If you define job
as the resource
that we use for the
batch view on job,
you can create a Spark job.
You can create an
Airflow cluster.
And these become part of the API
in fundamentally the same way
as any other resource.
To act on them, though, you need
to bring a custom controller.
So all the resources that
we've talked about so far--
each have a controller
that ships with Kubernetes.
But you can easily install
your own controller
to act on the
resources you define.
So, we've talked a lot about
the pieces of these data
processing pipelines.
The question is, how do I
get those on to my cluster?
So one way to do this
is using manifests.
And a manifest is
basically just a YML file
that contains most
of those atoms
that we talked about before.
You deploy it, you
apply it, it runs,
and it creates the
workload for you.
The problem with
this is, if you're
trying to get something
off of the shelf,
like go get a YML file that
somebody else has created
and deploy it into your
cluster, what if your monitoring
solution isn't the same as
the one that was found online?
Or what if your
lifecycle management
solution is totally different?
The manifest isn't really
portable from that perspective.
So in comes Helm.
Now Helm is a Kubernetes
package manager,
and what it allows you to do
is to template those manifests
and apply a set
of values to them.
So, it still doesn't solve
for lifecycle management.
But let's say you have
a template for the login
solution.
You can just plug that
in via values.yml.
If you want to
change configuration,
a values.yml will allow
you to change that.
But really for
complicated orchestration,
which is typically the use case
we see for data processing,
it's still not sufficient.
So, if you combine a custom
controller with a custom
resource, you get
what's colloquially
called the operator pattern.
So the operator
pattern is basically,
I'm going to teach my cluster to
understand what a Spark job is.
Then I'm going to
write a controller
to act on that
Spark job, and I'm
going to encode the day one and
day two operations necessary
for keeping that cluster up
inside of that controller,
inside of that operator.
And that seems to be the
dominant way that we're
approaching the problem.
My colleagues are going to
give you some demos later on,
contributions that we've
made to the community,
in particular for this.
PALAK DALAL BHATIA:
So, just diving
a bit deeper into operators.
For users to really trust
Kubernetes to run production
workloads like
databases, it needs
to be super easy to automate it.
And the way to scale it
is to actually automate
how you manage it.
An application
operator is basically
like a robot,
which performs some
of those functions of an
app's [? ops group. ?]
Think of a DBA.
How critical a DBA
is to the enterprise.
So this is really useful
for stateful applications.
They encapsulate the
operational concerns
of running an application
on Kubernetes,
and they run these applications
in a declarative fashion,
which Kubernetes understands.
The control loop observes
the existing state.
It looks at what the
desired state is.
It sees what difference is
needed, and then acts upon
the system to actually
reach that desired state.
Now I'll talk about how Google
Kubernetes Engine is providing
some of the best
tools and technologies
to run those data
processing workloads.
We recently launched
a marketplace
called GCP Marketplace,
and recently launched
the Kubernetes
section within it.
So what that means is now
the GCP Marketplace has
native integration into GKE.
You can click to deploy
stateful applications on GKE,
view those applications on the
UI as well as on your console.
We made available first-party
Google Developed solutions
like Spark and
Airflow to start with,
as well as several third-party
solutions by vendors.
Besides that, we have also been
leading open-source efforts
to develop something
called an app resource.
Previously, there was no
concept of an application
in Kubernetes.
There were a bunch of
workload controllers,
like DeploymentSets,
StatefulSets, and others,
but we didn't define
an application.
With this app
resource, you can now
view and manage an application
effectively on Kubernetes.
You can also leverage some of
the cutting edge data services
that GCP provides.
For instance, BigQuery, CloudAI,
Stackdriver, TPUs, and GPUs.
You can natively integrate those
on your Kubernetes applications
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
So, the first operator
that we launched
was the Spark Operator.
We had seen from users
that many of them
want to run data processing
and batch analytics
workloads on Kubernetes,
in a way, which
is native to Kubernetes.
They wanted to use kubectl
when running their Spark jobs.
The Spark Operator is
available on GitHub as well as
on the GCP Marketplace.
And I would like to invite
Yinan Li, who leads the Spark
Operator, to give a demo and
talk more about the operator.
YINAN LI: Thanks, Palak.
So, before I start, I just want
to get a sense, how many of you
run a Spark on
Kubernetes already?
OK, quite a few.
OK, hopefully the number will
get bigger after the talk.
So, the Spark
Operator is basically
a project that follows the
recent operator pattern.
So, at its core, there's
some custom resource types--
and also the corresponding
custom controllers
that extend the
Kubernetes API and control
plane with application domain
knowledge-- in this case,
will be Spark.
So there's actually two
types of custom resources.
One is called Spark application,
which is one time Spark jobs.
There's also a scheduled
Spark application time, which
is for time-based applications.
So you can actually
run a cross schedule
for your Spark applications.
The Spark Operator is basically
a custom controller that
watches these custom resources.
And once it sees
them, if there's
any new resources
coming, or there's
any updates to
existing resources,
it will actually take actions.
So in the case of
Spark, it will actually
run spark-submit for you.
So you don't need to
run that manually.
And once the application
gets submitted,
it will actually monitor to
the pods for the applications
for you, and aggregates
status into the status section
of your custom resource object.
So you can actually
get the status
of your application
in one place instead
of actually going through
all the pods individually.
So let me switch to
the demo machine.
So, this is where
the project's hosted.
Feel free to take a
look and try it out.
So before I start,
the first thing
I'm going to show
you actually, is
how an application looks like.
So this is a Spark
Application custom resource.
So you can actually
see, it allows
you to specify pretty much
every piece of information
your Spark application needs.
What is the main
class you want to use?
What is the main application
file you want to use?
In this case, the
application-jar
is actually hosted on GCS.
And runtime will be
downloaded by the driver
before it gets launched.
And you can also specify
the application-arguments
and what kind of
image you want to use,
and Spark Hadoop
configuration you want
to use for your application.
And then it has
a section for you
to specify all
your dependencies.
You can actually use remote
dependency on HDV servers,
or GCS, or on your
on-prem HDFS clusters.
And there's also
separate sections for you
to specify how the driver and
executor should look like.
In this particular case, the
application I'm going to demo
is one that tried to
find out on GitHub,
what are the goal
on GitHub projects
that needs help from
contributors the most?
So this particular
application will actually
read public GitHub
data set on BigQuery.
And then writes the
result back to BigQuery.
And intermediate result
will be written to GCS.
It's actually interacting
with both BigQuery and GCS
at the same time.
OK, so, the first
thing I'm going to do
is to create this
custom resource object.
For this, you can either
use kubectl or the Spark
Operator also ships
with a command
line tool called
Spark Control, which
makes dealing with these
custom resources even easier.
So, what happens, this actually
creates this custom resource
to the API server.
So once that's done,
the custom controller
will actually see this new
custom resource object,
and will actually run
spark-submit for you,
and that will create
the driver pod.
So after that, I'm going to
demo how you can actually
grab logs from the driver.
So you can see this is actually
grabbing the driver logs.
You can also do streaming.
This will basically be there,
and when more logs come in,
it will show you.
You can also actually not
only grab the driver log,
also logs of executor pods.
So to do that, you just
use the dash-E option,
then you basically tell
it what is that executor
ID you're interested in.
This case, if I say,
one, so this actually
fetched the logs
off executor one.
So that's for logs.
So, this command
line tool also comes
with the status
sub-command for you
to actually check what is the
current status of the app.
Or show you the driver pod name,
where the driver is running.
And also the individual states
of each individual executor
pod.
So you can also use kubectl
describe to do the same thing.
It will give you also the entire
spec of your custom object,
as well.
So the next thing
I'm going to show
is actually to see how we can
access this Spark driver UI.
So the UI is running
inside the driver.
To do that, I'm going
to do port forwarding
from my local machine
to the driver pod.
So if you actually
use kubectl, you
have to basically know what
is the name of the driver pod.
But if you use sparkctl,
you don't need to do that,
because we know where
the driver is running.
So we can do that automatically.
OK, so, this is actually
forwarding from 4040 to 4040
on the driver pod.
So you see the driver
UI, and it gives you
information about
individual executor as well.
So in this case, the actual
stages haven't started.
But you get a sense how
you can access the driver
UI using port forwarding.
So, this is actually
pretty straightforward.
So, the app is actually
running on a GKE cluster here.
So, if I do a
refresh, you can see
one driver pod got launched.
Then it's actually created
three executor pods, So off
and running.
So, let's stop this.
Once your app is done, you
want to get rid of these pods.
What you can do is
actually just to do this.
Then it will delete your Spark
application custom object,
and in turn, you know all your
pods will be gone after this.
So, this is pretty much
what I want to demo today.
But you can definitely
check out the documentation
on the GitHub site about other
features that we provide.
You can also run
Chrome-based applications.
And also, you can even actually
use the sparkctl command line
tool to automatically shape
your local dependency to GCS.
So you don't have
to do that manually.
So what happens if you
have local dependencies
in your application
specification,
sparkctl will actually
see them, and upload them
to a bucket you specify.
Then will actually
do a substitution
from these local dependencies to
the corresponding ones on GCS.
Then submit the converted
Spark application spec
to the API server.
So you don't need to do these
kind of things manually.
Everything is handled for you.
So, definitely go ahead and
check out our GitHub site
about documentations,
those kind of things.
So we've also got Slack channel.
Feel free to join, and
post questions or comments.
Thanks.
Next I'm going to hand
it over to my colleague,
Barney, who works on Airflow
and elastic search, those kind
of things on Kubernetes.
So he will be giving
a demo on the Airflow
Operator on Kubernetes.
Thanks.
BARNEY: Hi, my name is Barney.
I work in Google as part
of the Kubernetes team.
I'm here to present about
the Airflow Operator.
Before I tell what the
Airflow operator does,
let's take a look at
what an Airflow is.
Airflow is a platform
for deploying, managing,
scheduling, and
monitoring workflows.
A workflow is a DAG,
Directed Acyclic Graph,
written in Python.
A typical installation
of Airflow
has many components, like
the UI scheduler workers,
and the broker and
the sequel node.
So deploying Airflow
is a complex endeavor,
with many moving parts, and
different configurations
for each of the components.
The way it's typically deployed
right now is using Helm charts.
But like Ken mentioned,
that does not
take care of the lifecycle
management of an Airflow
deployment.
And also the developer
experience with an Airflow
is lacking, because you need
to copy the DAGs that you
are developing into the cluster,
before you can test it out.
And if you expect individual
developers to stand up
their own clusters, it's not
an easy thing for them to do.
And this where the
Airflow Operator comes in.
The Airflow Operator
is a custom resource.
It's a bunch of custom resources
with a custom controller.
What it does is, it makes
it dead easy and simple
to deploy Airflow on Kubernetes.
I just mentioned
custom resources.
A custom resource is
a declarative spec
that tells you what to
do, and not how to do it.
And there are two
custom resources
that the Airflow Operator works
on-- the base, and the cluster.
Let's switch to the
demo and I can show you
how the resources look.
All right, there you go.
I hope you guys can see
it all in the screen.
All right, there you go.
This is the base resource.
The base resource has
two components, a MySQL
and NFS storage.
The cluster resource has the
rest of Airflow components,
like the UI scheduler
worker nodes and the broker.
So if you notice, the CRD spec
for the base is very minimal.
You don't have to
specify the images,
or how you bring up
MySQL, how do you
set up the database inside it.
The username, the root
password, all of it
is taken care of by
the Airflow Operator.
But you could customize
the custom resource
by specifying your own resource
requirements or placement
properties.
The good thing is, it just uses
kubectl to create and manage
these custom resources.
Let's deploy this.
And before that, let
me start the Operator.
So I'm creating the
custom resource.
And you can notice on
the logs on the left,
that the Operator would start
picking up this custom resource
and deploying the StatefulSets
and other resources that
are needed for standing it up.
You see that it created the
MySQL StatefulSet as well
as an NFS StatefulSet.
And you also see it created a
secret dynamically for setting
up the root password for MySQL.
And the pod's already
at this point.
Let's look at the
other custom resource.
So this is a cluster
custom resource.
We can pick the executor
of choice for Airflow.
But what I'm using
is CeleryExecutor,
which is a multi-node
deployment of Airflow.
And we use Redis as the broker.
And all we need to say is which
version of the Airflow image
that you want to use.
And you also notice
that there's the DAG
section, where you specify
where the DAGs need
to be pulled from.
And this makes it dead
simple for someone
using Airflow to specify
all the their environment
in the same file, and
let the Operator do
the deployment for them.
I'm creating the cluster CRD.
And you notice that the
operator is deploying
the parts and the
StatefulSet Notice
that two new secrets
have been created--
one for Redis and one
for the scheduler.
So what the operator does is, it
creates a database dynamically
in MySQL for this instance
of Airflow cluster.
So you have the
UI, you have Redis,
you have a scheduler,
and two worker
nodes that are up and running.
We'll give it a
couple of seconds,
and try to access this
to see if it's up.
Typically we do port
forwarding to access it,
because it's easier that way.
So your Airflow cluster is up.
We can run a quick test to
make sure that it's working.
Run a DAG.
So these are the
tasks it's running.
Once it's completed, I will
show you how the DAG looks like.
It's almost done.
There it goes.
So it shows that it ran
the DAG three times.
This was triggered by me.
And if you open the Dag, this
is how the steps within the DAG
look like.
So we have deployed a
working Airflow cluster
within a couple of minutes,
and we were able to test it.
Let's take a look at
the configuration here.
You notice that it's set to be--
the executor is CeleryExecutor.
And if you look at the
connection string for MySQL,
you notice that
it auto-generates
a username, password, as
well as the database that
needs to be used for
this Airflow instance.
And it connects
to the MC base SQL
that we deployed earlier
as part of the base CRD.
So MC base, MySQL.
So I just demoed how easy it is
to deploy a multi-node Airflow
cluster using two CRDs.
Let's go ahead and
deploy one more cluster.
All right, this time I'm going
to deploy Celery with the GCS
as the DAG source.
Maybe I'll show how it
looks like before deploying.
You notice it's almost
similar to the earlier cluster
configuration, except that
you point to the GCS bucket
as DAG source.
All right, it's deployed
the second Airflow cluster.
If you notice, I
didn't deploy the base
for the second cluster.
It reuses the base
from the first cluster.
You could do it this way
to improve resource usage,
and this is particularly
useful if you
want disposable
development clusters
that you want to hand it
over to the developers.
Now, let's try connecting
to the new cluster.
And this is the second
cluster we just deployed.
And notice that it doesn't
have the state here,
because it's brand new.
And if you look at the
configuration for My SQL,
let's go back here.
If you notice it has a
different connection string,
because these were
dynamically generated
for the second cluster.
And this is how we are
able to share the same base
across components.
I'm sorry, clusters.
All right, let me go ahead
and deploy one more cluster.
And this is something new.
OK, that's cluster.
There is something different
about this cluster.
If you notice, it doesn't
deploy the worker nodes.
It just deploys the
UI and the scheduler.
The reason is, this cluster uses
the Kubernetes executor, which
does not need worker
nodes to be pre-deployed.
Sorry.
All right, here you go.
The executor is Kubernetes here.
So what happens
is when you run--
let me connect to the new one.
All right, so let's look
at the configuration
for the new cluster.
If you notice, it's using
the Kubernetes executor
at this point.
And of course the
MySQL string is
going to be different from
the other two clusters.
I just fired.
You notice that it's
generating pods on the fly.
So all the tasks in your
DAG will end up as pods.
It's similar to
the Spark Operator.
The good part about
this is you don't
need to have dedicated worker
pods running all the time,
and there are some use
cases where it's useful.
So that's the
Kubernetes executor.
So if you notice,
the Operator makes
it easy to deploy Airflow with
different configurations-- one
with CeleryExecutor, one
with Kubernetes executor.
And a developer could also
use the local or a sequential
executor as well.
And you're able to do all
this with just two custom
resources against this
many StatefulSets, secrets,
and all these things.
And it's not just the deployment
that the Airflow cluster
takes care of.
It also takes care of
managing data operations,
like if you want to scale out.
If you want to horizontally
scale a cluster that you
already deployed, you can
edit the custom resource
and change the replicas.
So I'm going to
bump it up to four.
All right, you'll see
that it's creating
the new workers for the first
cluster that we deployed.
So what does underlying
is it goes and bumps up
the replica for the StatefulSet,
which in turn creates
new pods for you.
And you could also change the
executor type of your cluster
once it's deployed.
So, for example, if you
deployed a CeleryExecutor
and switch it to Kubernetes,
it deletes the worker nodes
for you.
So it gives you that
dynamic ability.
And it's not just
scaling and deployment,
it also makes sure your
clusters are resilient.
What I mean by
that is, Kubernetes
does a good job of handling
pod failures are node failures.
But if someone accidentally
deletes your StatefulSet,
the executor monitors that
and it recreates it for you.
It just makes it a
little bit more resilient
than just using
Kubernetes manifests.
And what else?
All right, I think
that's about it.
Thank you, guys.
PALAK DALAL BHATIA:
So if there are
three things that you want to
take away from this session,
they are as follows.
Number one, Kubernetes
is no longer
the platform for just
running stateless services.
You can now run complex stateful
applications on Kubernetes
and manage them in
a very easy way.
You just saw two amazing
demos on Spark and Airflow,
which could be run and managed
in just a couple of minutes.
Secondly, with the
use of operators
you can perform Day
N kind of operations,
not just on Google
Cloud, but on any cloud.
You can run those operators
on your private data centers,
and have the portability and
the consistent experience
that you want across your
clouds for the business
critical multi-cloud strategy.
You can discover
these applications
on the GCP Marketplace
to begin with,
including the Spark
and Airflow Operators.
And third, Google Cloud
provides some of the best tools
to run these
applications on GKE.
If you want to run an
open-source service,
you can use Spark and Airflow.
But if you want managed
service with SLAs as well
as production-grade
support, you can
use DataPlug as well
as Cloud Composer
for these managed instances.
You can integrate with
some of the other GCP
services like BigQuery, Cloud
Storage, Stackdriver, GPUs,
and TPUs into your
Kubernetes clusters.
And click to deploy
these applications
on GKE, not just from Google but
also from third-party partners
that we are working
very closely with.
Thank you for your time, and
we welcome any questions.